pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
with all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations so at
this point top gun maverick is the most
successful movie of the year it's
something i don't think anyone could
have predicted and in a time when comic
book movies dominate the landscape this
has come out and completely knocked it
out the park though i didn't even really
like the first film all that much i
think this is by far one of the best
movies of the year if not one of the
best sequels of all time i've wanted to
do a perfect scene video on it for a
while but the movie is just packed with
them to the point that i don't even
think i could have chosen a specific one
whether it's how they handle iceman the
scene where maverick shows the run can
be done to his students or the final
mission itself it's all laid out to feel
like some of the best cinema that we've
ever seen and it definitely deserves all
the praise it's getting
his exploits are legendary is called
sign
map
now throughout this video i want to talk
about why i love the movie so much what
it does differently to other equals and
also why it offers not only commentary
on those but also the state of hollywood
in general there's very much a style to
how modern reboots tend to work and in a
lot of cases they take an established
character from an old franchise show
they enj have the new guys come in and
pull them back so they can sacrifice
themselves and in the end a new
franchise starts up with lesser versions
of them at the helm there's very much
been this feeling in the fan community
that a lot of what hollywood does at the
moment is that it destroys the legacy
characters in favor of propping up newer
ones which can be seen across a number
of movies not to bang on about the last
jedi but this is a good example of this
in that it takes the idea of luke in the
jedi deconstructs what this means and
shows the flaws and the heroes that we
grew up with it then replaces them with
the new generation and i know a lot of
criticism about this technique in
hollywood is that it drops the ball with
characters that we love i actually think
the last jedi is alright don't shoot me
but even more camels seemed a bit
disappointed with how luke went out and
it's important to know that top gun
maverick does the exact opposite to this
it very much gives us the idea that just
because someone is old it doesn't mean
they're obsolete and this is exemplified
a maverick who constantly shows a new
generation that they can learn from him
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
it's a very important motif that is
laced throughout the film at several
points at the start maverick's detail is
threatened with being replaced by ed
harris's drone program he's not
initially allowed to go on the main
mission himself and this is feeling that
because he's from the older generation
that he's to be ignored however the
whole movie is about showing that the
old ways still work this is cemented in
the finale when we watch rooster and
maverick flying an older jed as they go
against the new fifth generation ones
however this idea extends beyond the
film itself and i think once we go
through this you'll perhaps even
appreciate the movie more than you
already do
tom cruise is very much seen as the last
movie star and even though he still
looks great for his age he's still seen
as an older actor however when you see
what he does in his films it really puts
the younger generation to shame this is
a guy who's climbing skyscrapers
dangling off the side of planes as they
take off and in this movie he also made
sure that they used as little cgi as
possible this adds to the authenticity
of the movie and in a time where films
are often more cgi than not he's shown
that the old ways are better top gun
maverick feels infinitely more impactful
than a lot of movies released today
because most of it is really happening
you sat in the cockpit with the pilots
themselves and you feel every single
twist turn and attack as they battle
their way out
this is a movie something that pulls
together over 100 years of filmmaking to
make one of the most immersive
experiences that you could ever have now
beyond this the idea of the old ways
being better also extends to its release
in the pandemic several studios realized
they were hitting a point where they had
to release their movies on streaming
services in order to make it so they
could still return a profit tom cruise
constantly pushed this phone back
because he wanted people to experience
it in a theater the way it was meant to
be again there's this idea of the old
ways being better than the new and in a
time where it's so easy to stay home and
stream stuff top gun has shown that the
cinema is still relevant watching this
in imax completely blew me away and it's
one of the most visceral times i've had
during a film now why is that well
that's what i want to discuss for the
next part of the video but first just a
quick word from our sponsors now if you
like taking care of your top gun then
you need to check out the new manscape
performance package 4.0 it's smooth sack
summer baby and this new kit has
everything you need to prepare for that
summer body when you go play volleyball
inside it you'll find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer which has a cutting edge ceramic
blade that has advanced skin safe
technology to protect you from getting
cut when you go into the danger zone it
also has a 4000k led light on it so you
can shave in the dark or in the daytime
if you just need a bit of extra light on
your face so you make sure you hit the
bullseye on top of that comes the weed
whacker which is the best ear and nose
trimmer that i've ever used i've been
using manscape for about a year now it's
quick very precise always gets the job
done and it's there exactly when i need
it now after you've given yourself the
perfect haircut you can use the crop
preserver ball deodorant spray it will
help you stay cool in the hot seat and
its soothing aloe vera formula is the
best in the business when it comes to
keeping you dry and smelling great
there's also the crop reviver and
manscaped have also thrown in two free
gifts this includes the anti-chafing box
of briefs that will mean your maverick
never gets a rash as well as the shed
travel bag that will protect your kid
wherever you go on top of this if you're
wearing sandals with some nasty toenails
make sure you check out this year's 2.0
luxury nail grooming kit it's got
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors to make sure that
the rest is covered go to manscape.com
and enter the code heavy spoilers at
checkout for 20 off and also free
shipping one more time so you don't
forget the rhyme we're going to say the
line mansgames.com code heavy spoilers
20 off and free shipping
and the blood of top gun works so well
because it's structured very much in the
same way that a heist movie is i know
there's a lot of comparisons to a new
hope and yet let's be honest the job
itself is very similar to the trench rod
even down to them needing to hit a
bull's eye on a specific point however i
think that a new hope is slightly more
varied due to it featuring this space
battle at the start tatooine the death
star lightsaber fight and then the final
battle love them both but yeah i think
maverick has set up more like a heist
where there's this one job that the
entire thing builds up to and they spend
the majority of the movie planning
towards this when they finally get to
the mission things go wrong and they
have to think on their feet in order to
get out alive the enemy much like the
police in a heist are closing in and
they're attempting to get out there on a
wing and a prayer before they get caught
although it's very flashy and over the
top in terms of its action set pieces
the film also has a real heart to it we
discover that goose's son rooster
attempted to follow in his father's
footsteps but due to a promise made to
his mother maverick has interfered with
his career early on we cut to his hangar
and see photos of not only goose but
also his son indicating how much
maverick cares about him however
maverick holding him back creates
tension between the two even though
there's clearly a lot of guilt still
felt over the death of goose
rooster is the son of goose who was
maverick's wingman and the first top gun
i got your back
there's been some complicated history
between rooster and maverick my dad
believed in you i'm not gonna make the
same mistake
now initially mavericks brought in as a
teacher who's there to train the best of
the best of the best sir these topkin
students have been hand selected to be
part of this highly imperative mission
and throughout we watches maverick tries
to guide them but it's clear that
something is holding them back whether
it's rooster flying too slow or hangman
leaving his team behind they all have
their faults but we watch as these are
endowed throughout the movie now
maverick isn't perfect either and he has
a bit of a strenuous relationship with
not only rooster but also penny this is
a girl he ended up walking out on and
though she still cares for him a lot it
shows that he's not completely upsetting
what can i say he's a bit of a maverick
now on top of this there's also iceman
who's handled in one of the most
respectful ways i think they could have
done in case you don't know val kilmer
was diagnosed with throat cancer and
this made it extremely difficult for him
to talk this is carried over to the
character too and thus a lot of the time
he talks through text
thus when he actually speaks it means
even more and his death carries a lot of
impact because he was such a strong
presence now it's clear that jon hamm's
cyclone bloody john harm he doesn't like
the way maverick does stuff and he kicks
him out of top gun he's clearly more
about the mission and doesn't even mind
that there will be lives lost if he gets
his way he takes over command and almost
doubles the time limit for the job
meaning that everyone will be setting
dirks once it's over
the entire team is down about the whole
thing and they now believe that their
lives will be lost because they're not
training to get out of there alive
that's when maverick comes in drops the
time down from 2 30 to 2 15 and one
shots the entire thing to prove it can
be done it'll make your fist pump the
air and he's brought back in for the
mission it's a real rush watching them
do it and the scene is elevated so much
by the filming style of the movie being
placed in the cockpit was fantastic and
it adds even more weight to it because
it feels like we're on the job too
however maverick sacrifices his jet in
order to save rooster and this leaves
him behind enemy lines just as he's
about to face certain death rooster
saves his life and together the pair
have to escape the cold nondescript
country before the chaos dies down and
the bad guys realize what's going on in
inferior planes they face off in
dogfights against jets that we've been
told throughout the movie are basically
terminators in the sky however as the
movie repeatedly tells us it's not the
plane it's the pilot and they actually
come out on top too but upon making
their way back to the ship another jet
comes to play a game of chicken with
them this scene is shot expertly too
with us truly believing that this might
be the end of them however han's salt
sorry hangman comes in at the last
second and he also redeems the faults
that he's been told he has throughout
the movie together maverick and rooster
hug it out with the ladder saying that
he saved him because it's what his dad
would have done even with a cheeky
little nod from cyclone this moment hit
me so hard and this celebration
beautifully echoed the one at the end of
the first movie that his father sadly
wasn't there for maverick made a promise
throughout the movie that he'd make sure
everyone got home and he very much did
most films like this would require some
sort of sacrifice with a hero going out
in a blaze of glory but this movie
brings everyone back it's very
aspirational and in a time where films
tend to be tearing down what's come
before to tell us how bad it all was top
gun maverick has a very traditional
style that feels inspirational more than
anything watching rooster take the hit
in the training mission and then at the
end against maverick shows what kind of
person you can be and i think this idea
stems from maverick and it even affects
the others hangman has a complete change
of heart and everyone in the movie grows
in a way that leaves them better off
than they were when they started it
shows that the past should be celebrated
that there's still relevancy in the
things that people are trying to replace
and hell the movie is just a good time
we close out with lady gaga's hold my
hand which perfectly fits the final
flight with penny and maverick watching
jennifer connolly standing next to the
sports car feels like a classic
throwback to the movies of yesteryear
and seeing the two soar through the
skies the sun sets is a beautiful way to
end the movie plays throughout this are
shots of rooster and the photo of him
and his father gets a new addition with
a celebration on the ship it closes out
what is a perfect film though slightly
by the numbers shows that sometimes the
old ways are the best whether it's the
practicality of the effects the
dedication that the cast put into making
sure the scenes were as real as they
could be or the respect that it shows
its characters everything here works top
gun maverick is a classic and in years
to come it will be seen as the blueprint
of how to do a hollywood movie that
brings people together rather than
dividing them
the end is inevitable maverick the kind
is headed for extinction
maybe so sir
but not today come on
having any fun yet
i really believe it's something that
everyone can find enjoyment in and i
hope you had as much fun listening to me
talk about it as i did making this video
and obviously love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of dr strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film you pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that's you they're messaging me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out upright another perfect
scene in the boys season 3 which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
the fight at the end of episode 6 and
all the elements are built towards it so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if not then thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
poor i hope to see you next time take
care peace